being black in America you have to have
two eyes go and you have to have the I
mean you see the world with and the eyes
of the world sees you with my name's W
kamau Bell and I'm a stand-up comedian
and professional talker I think people
who aren't black men or art intimately
related to or engage with black men are
finding out something that black man
always knew and grew up knowing is that
you know we are looked at as targets by
America at large
either that we're going to do something
bad or about to do something bad or we
need to stop before we do some you know
there's a whole series of thing that as
a black man in the world that I was made
aware of by my mom and the only thing
that has changed is that now there's
more evidence of it the worst thing
that's happened to me because of racism
is walking around every day being aware
that I can be killed for no reason at
all and knowing that it's on me to stop
that from happening I can't trust the be
that the police are gonna stop to happen
other people around me are sessile
message I had to sort of try to go out
in the world with the home train and my
mom gave me and try to make sure I don't
end up in a situation where I'm going to
be killed for no reason at all by a
police officer
fans don't like you a wake-up call
Trayvon Martin certain Selleck another
wake-up call and now here we are with
Mike Brown and we've not that far past
our gardener and somewhere right now in
the streets sadly is some black man
who's walking around was going to be
murdered by a police officer and it's
just my job to do all I can to make sure
I'm not that black man doesn't mean I
can control it it can happen at any time
for any reason as we've seen from all
these things but it's my job because I
have a wife and a daughter and the
daughter on the way and I'd like to be
around them to make sure to try to make
sure it's not me
subscribe on YouTube follow us on
Twitter and like us on Facebook